じゃあ肇社長です皆さん
もの
大雪でしていますかまたも一番 youtube 上でも残してるの僕なんですけど
こんな僕でも大切にしているものって結構ありましてその中の一つが
壊れてしまいました
んいやでももうねぇ
んだ気を使ったからしゃーねーって知らないと思うんですけど
こちらです
めっちゃきたねーだろ b って書いてるかちょっとよくわかんないんですけどこの
財布
北5年間1回も変えずに使ってきましたいろんな人に汚いとか財布変えるとか3つ言わ
れたんですけど僕こう見えてもの大切にするんですよ
説得力ねーなった方でしょ動画で使ってねものとか動画でも残しているものは動画の
ものだと思って
動画でそういう風で使われるために買ったって僕は割り切ってるからそういう扱いに
なっちゃうわけなんですけど
普段使ってるものとか結構ネズミに大雪でしたりしてて
まあならサンダルとかも普通にさん米入ったりこのナイフももちろんそういうたぐいで
どこで買ったかといいますとなると
百円ショップ百円ショップで買った財布を年間大切に使わせていただきますチャックと
かねもう
課程1年合計ないからもなくなってたんですけどこれ別に猫 is 日で呆れるかいい
んですけどもう使えないなって思うで壊れた原因がありますねちょっと見ますカード
入れるところスって心札入れるところ骨も使ったら
を投げ正名もうポロポロですどこ壊れるかって言いますとの小銭エコなんですよもう
こんな化に貢献が入ってるんですけどちょっと画面てっておりますねスカウティング
ない状態だとちょっとしまったでしょ
小銭落ちてくるんですよ僕これ知らずに東京で歩いててうわめっちゃ俺小銭をとしてる
やんと思ってサイト見たら
破れてますここですね今後も破れててはくに出ても
カーンちっと出てしまう何度亡くしたことがこの財布の僕操作はなんか慌ててると絶対
ものを忘れたりなくしたりするんですけどボロいせいか何があっても絶対僕の元に帰っ
て来てくれる不思議な財布でしたそれこんなボロいサイクだったらさせる2台もドイツ
語とは思わしまぁいろんな何かがあって必ず僕の元に返ってくるというしてください
でしたもう
使えないです小銭が落ちてくるようじゃあもう本当に怖いですね
[音楽]
臭いほんときたに回してきたねきったねぇねぇけどねぇ
これじゃないと嫌だったんですよねいやーなんかはなしーというか結ぶはよく5年間
ここまでやってくれたなと思います
もう俺タバサ誘拐だとしても最後にこれこれのイメージがあるからねちょっと慣れない
と思うんだはやめ
者様がってもう誰に馬鹿にされようとも絶対これを
使ってましたからまあそれでよくなくしていた財布がわかりというわけでございますと
いうわけで本当に5年間8日一度も娘レズ
僕がどこかに忘れても必ず僕の元に帰って来てくれてバタバタしてた僕を支えてくれた
素晴らしい最高でした
[音楽]
ちょっと感動する700年間本当にありがとうございますはぁ
by だけど本当に心でございますこの際風邪ないってなると俺は次どんな財布買おう
かなと思ってすごい悩んでるわけでございますよ俺先にと言いましょうたぶん普通の
対応を買ってもないします僕が今日つけるどうこうより多分もなくす全然で動いた方が
いいと思ってるんで多分なくしますというわけで俺が終わってください
どんなやつを買おうかと言いますとこれはもうそんで100円ショ
デカッすぐ良かったってことねつぎ
おちゃうっ
塩の f をか小沢ない
[音楽]
[拍手]
100万円です皆さん勘違いされてくださいこれじゃんの作成がありまして
財布が100万円だったとしましょうなくすわけないでしょこれならやっぱり安いもの
の3位女だから僕ちょっとどこが気を許しているところがあってぽいけど買わせたりし
てなんですけど配布時代が100万円だとしましょう盗まれただけで100万円の村内
ああああだ絶対忘れないと思うんですよ逆の発想でも100円
来やすいんだったら100万円にすれば絶対になくさないんじゃないか
待ってってかそもそも100万なさいとある
なく猫様から100までください候補5最近探しておりました
なんかこういうのは使っていろんなネットワーク使って頑張って探したんですけど
それっぽいのがあったんで今から鯉ずの石を受け継げ第二の100万円な財布
東京にあるらしいんですよまだなんかどこのメーカーとかどんなのかも全く知らないん
ですよ値段等100万円っていうのが大事だと思ったんで雑則100万円だ最高
手に入れ
ていこうと思います出会いやこれ100万円曲ですよねアイガー
前田家東京つきましたここ敗2分けで再公開に
東京まで行ってまいりましたうーん
あっほんと見せびらかすもんじゃないんですけど実物はカルト
ちょっと嫌だったブランドもわからないしロゴのお店がわからないその問題の
100万円なさい打っているてお店はどこですか
まあまあ決まって動かすと思ってるでしょ
ずってことでしょうね
the ちゃうチェーン違うを図った
またそこをこれだこれだ
それだからこそ自分で調べたんですけど山中700万円固有歳っていうのは売ってない
おっとここでまた50万くらいが結構限界だったんで
売ってないんだよねその反対に2つだけエルメス行ってみようと思います
[音楽]
を混ぜバイマジでヤバイマジでねまずではほんま1コマまずじゃないって何がでややば
もうバズ者は行って前はかよかったよ
企画だかわかったけどさぁもマジでやばいってもこれ
えっお前何って言ってたこれ100万円と言ってるのは俺
100万円以上だったら面白いと思って170万円にしましたをマーカーやー
お金するのは
[音楽]
ブーバーちょっちょっでちょっちょっと待っててくださいね所詮ん
a いやべえ on 100万曲で追い上げるはマジヤバイ
どうでした花王
ブーブーちゃんの行政を持ってきたところ色
ねえだろほら n の0うーんバッハロスを如意
えタクシーはいという議論を買ってきました
100名墓んだった100万円だと思ったら
176万円だが左右でございいう
いやもういいんですよ俺吹っ切れてるよ種がとまんねぇでは体の異変がすごいそれそう
ですわなぁ
2の人間のする買いもんじゃねーかねお店の中の今日は鮮明に覚えております鮮明に
覚えていますがあの商品のデザインは全く覚えていません
ああすごいやばい事してんだって気持ちになってて恵比寿の店なんかちっちゃい女の子
二人来て言ってなかっハザー
ててる時に僕100万円の札束こうやって持ってドーンと言ってましたから
若干聞かれましたねあとすぎを貼る奴に見えたと思いますというわけで上げていき
ましょう
本件でなんとしか見ていいレベルです今中に入っております
いや高レア
塩蔵たことですね財布ケリーロング ia たーーー
西氏ってなんでしょうきゃっ97160,400円
これすごいねぇ oi で
な by マジでやばいいるだけでこちらが外れご覧ください
ホンダ100万円危険後にこの思ってたんですよ200万円分私がてこれでもうばあ
さんでこれ見て100万円結果終了でございます杉様ありがとうございまず
残り香に柔軟まちょっとメインの動画とかねが別のないかに使ったりするんだよねば
あげていきましょうつーかにズームで店だけでねいい
市長瀬76万ですっちゃか俺すごいことに気づいたんですけどエルメスのお店にいる人
だってもなんかすごそうだった
結局あの値段変わっても所詮は財布ですからね
僕はこいつと同じ使い方をさせていただきます愛理がすご
ああ怖い待って強い強い子はマジで怖いこれはもうやっぱコレのこの世界ですよあり
エーターって書いてたらきっとバニーさんなんでしょうね
めっちゃくちゃ希少な物って言われましたこれだけこの年かカーディガンの切れ端
みたいなこれはお金に含まれませんよね
こういうことにカード入れがあって
小枝を小銭入れが徹底感ですね
ちゃんと
ns って書いてあります芸めっちゃ失礼なこというと勝わかんねー
いやぁーだわかってますあのアリゲーターのかが稼ぐんでしょうねあと ls という
ブランドもすばらしいです取り上げてデータ移行します
ていた際虞翻台より中身が高くなることないんだろうなんておっ
分かったいやもう俺なくさに自信しかねえんだこれ
+が2年も無くさない自信しかないですね大休憩で無事
176万円の台風に4,762円が入りました
振動スペースがすげーなーやっぱり100円の財布と違うなぁ顔だからからさ
今硬いんですよねこれパンツ買っていけばどんどん慣れてくるみたいなもんなんかな
無事入りましたいやんでかっけーでも桜
[音楽]
おおおおう
me
入ってゆけでサインを新しくします
かっこいいのパッと見ながらこういうクラッチバックみたいに見えるね大事に使わせて
いただきます
ありがとうございました乗客早速この176万持ってあのみんなに見せびらかして
いこうと思います
出会い子は誰やー
aname
あれが楽しくしたなうわーええんおお
ふーん元祖バーン信者や黒子だよ
マダムだ寝るんです
バカじゃねぇ
[音楽]
me
うううう
バッハ